well to Mexico now authorities have
begun removing Central American migrants
from an overcrowded shelter in Tijuana
they're boarding buses that will take
them to another location which is
further away from the border around
7,000 migrants had been staying in the
Benito Juarez Sports Complex while
waiting to reach the US to apply for
asylum but the facility was overcrowded
leading to squalid conditions all right
let's pull in our correspondent Stefan
is he months he is next to the new
shelter there in Tijuana I understand
good evening to you Stefan
where are the migrants going to stay now
and are we talking about better
conditions for them well I would like to
answer that question about the better
conditions to you but I can't really
because let me show you this gate here
is for press for now for another two
hours the end of excess is you can see
they're closing and now this is where
the where the migrants will now go in
and we'll have their new home we are
told by by riff by migrants which came
out in which we talked to that this
place is much better than what they were
used to and had to endure in the Vanita
who where sports center location there
which took a dive to the worst in the
last two days because of horrendous rain
here so here in this shout that we're
told there will be women and men single
men and singing women separated families
will have their own space there will be
protection for them there will be walls
there were no walls in the other Center
now it's getting a little loud here let
me show you this what's going on here
all those people here are a hungry and
to Thursday and they're now going to
stand in line here where we go the
camera show you this way a little bit
down there there are donations for food
and water and a few clothes and those
guys are standing in line now to pick
this up so bottom line we are told
everything will be better here the
reason for moving about 7,000 migrants
from Central America from the old
location here is
we are told that the conditions of
course in benito juarez were absolutely
at horrid and and absolutely
unsustainable and you have the pictures
you have seen the pictures people were
wading through water until to their
ankles etcetera so this should be a
better place in two hours we get a first
look and then we'll see how this really
pans out yeah it would be nice to get a
look because it's hard to understand why
they would be so secretive now if this
new center is going to be an improvement
and there has been some criticism about
this move we understand yeah from
observers and some who are like let's
say professional activists in the whole
migration thing they're saying this is
of course a double sore here a double
plate because now all those people are
far away from the border farther away
from the boy there's no chance anybody's
jumping the fence here or makes it even
close to the border there are mountains
between their new shelter now and the
border to the United States of America
number one number two access here is for
even for media or anybody who wants to
help this is 40 45 minutes away without
traffic from downtown and if you want to
report from here or you want to do
anything from here
you have to spend another two days on of
your dad's just driving here so the fear
of immigration professionals people who
are involved in helping those people is
that in a week or so nobody is actually
remembering this anymore nobody's
reporting about this anymore
the migrants themselves I don't think
have processed that yet they are
predominantly happier I think and what
we have heard so far that they're in a
new location with dry feet and better
services yeah
out of sight out of mind our
correspondent Stefan Zimmerman's in
Tijuana Mexico on the story for its
delight Stefan thank you